and we also got some couples news from
newlywed Dwayne rock Johnson he just
tied the knot with Lauren hashing but is
he getting heat for not inviting this
friend it's a beautiful day and we got
married in Hawaii as a matter of fact
probably know well I thought I said hey
you and John you should come it was
literally an hour before you got married
oh I'm in Buffalo that's the way your
make it I need my own it's a bummer you
know I was in but she was above yeah you
guys want to go I'm like we can't Oh
watch out Kevin Hart emily is Dwayne's
new comedy partner in Jungle Cruise
based on the fame welcome to Jungle
Cruise it's gonna be great
the adventure of a lifetime wait I'm
sorry sorry wait we argue about who's
the biggest story
he's already learning those lessons
happy life happy wife happy life good
job and it's happy wife happy life for
Chris Pratt he and Katherine
Schwarzenegger got hitched back in June
how's married life
aw man I'm like God is good I feel
really good really blessed yeah Wow
Chris and Tom Holland are having an
Avengers reunion of their own there the
voices of elf brothers in the Disney
Pixar animated movie on Sunday bro our
destiny awaits okay I'm coming you think
about that when you're picking movies
now like I want Jack to be able to see
these movies I want him to be able to
experience this stuff with me I mean for
sure yeah this movie is so good
[Applause]
[Music]